tonal to who had shifting bierce and
who are talking about
theory of digs new networks and
who in particolare king pascal there even
love expressive arjuna networks watergraf
neural networks able to learn and my
card and not able to learn this is
really
the question for  this part of the reading
so wie talkabout deep neural networks
i'd like to grass yard through several
layers of no more propulsion we
year try to come up reed and bindings of
emergency
initiation is of networks last week
a goal work skies of
machine learning  prediction touches the kiwi
ideal that graph now the network is sharp
those are those off and gray pink local take
it well the battery monologue interest to
generate the impending for the
resolutions can on the classic picture
wifi showing
several times in in our discussions
so often  lost so that douche and is
that notes
jack great information from their
neighbors using new networks and such a
families closet some way design crysis
y  ou came when deciding how to check out
to operational eyes continue doe design
it's a knife x transformation
inactivation operations zo to-day right
now we're going to talk about
so theory about graff nu spacious networks
a particle there through their klaas keeps
powerfull  achraf new networks soon
expression where they walk in the learn
and walk in the not learn
auditions special import and that chance
thirdr many different
jane and mom write you grab the ball the
juicy his grave could give him his new
laptop piet on certain the graph
action network
who picks up the built de graaf senior
network in the talked about the entire
design space of the stars of models on
sunday question is what is the
berg expressive power with basic en is
wat is eraf beauty
to the sting with different note the
frog structures
aan en  go expressive arm die in
learning the phone box of patents and
then what do that super good idea is that
now baby i excelior to design
the mac simoni expressive jane en m  an
sorry some sense
ww-what do design the most powerfull
count now laennec get something on
walls
super cool they pay attention the third place will
background cradle and many engraving network
models the whole f diferent
theory that for you intensely also all that
propagates aggregate  en transvorm
messages
a min the question is kimmy understand
what is there
expressive power in gold Lieffering
design choices and julie
league two different type' of
market so before i could dig simple hereafter
shady to now that fake of the sea
and the queue see what  is column in
pulling gripe so busy am wendy
aggregate information from de nemer
million cells man and my twice
limbolink
and then you a linear transformation
pras plasser and i you
a non-linear net for me simple what
it is jc and but nutrition psychologist
adheres to  users and you must tasty recipe
rang pee
elemend live only a maximum pulling
songs
which different and the question is what
is better is mix better than  than
ever hear what is the difference
between the two
in terms of injury that I also drive
properties in expressing power to this
is an import and
attend milk arena make so that donk and
computer on in canal now works the same
who gave two respect
crib en the respect of distress features
distress properties en him the effect of
graff structure and for the purpose of
this lecture and going to use color is
of notes to the present their feature
factors
then they cool so a
feature became him so a feature
representation
my driver shampoo
this graff here numbers' repris are all
those not so like and share and gasket
building knol i'm talking about need
to
bake the features that snood screen parool
de ccd  snow and feature information
to that poor to the steam with notes
from an honor
bright so evident who I am not
in the least what is the feature vector or the no-show
name for a sample de peshan ge  offer
go to work to guyenne and knew english
that strange graph and structures
we de cozy ferdinand border something already
unique and feature notices there i think easy
to this team vision on just look at
their feature alarm clocks
what you for the feature arouses sardes
a corpse in it  this case of nota riello
ben the issue scan your steam that
incentive can you learn that you have never been
5 prefer and the need for nutrition
sampling skates
so on and in graaf mother networks
more private interest now nice
motion of local take good structures
work  this claim more interest in plank
in fine the local network take good care
of space something nut in de count
zo for exemple geer let em interest
die note one in five en he say goodbye
learn to the sting with no one in five
the sting machine and  would be quite
easy because they have different take
good structures in my iq look at the
number of ends that he uit aceh
sense to each of them you never is
little degree to en nood  5633 so on
you to be very easy to the sting with dan
don't succeed
capture the degree of the nut in dan
gravure network i think a
differentiate between distress one in five
led candy channel on the circle
hello never fails man and for
judgment is  team vision write review look
at it from the see the
layer single hole take good and need
little is yours and note for his
degree to
would you from joni and heaven to capture the
degree of the notes icon on the french
ep-  10 cheek and toe drive him so a
feature woke him the same degree
however one and two are still different
that passion of yucca flats in the second
degree neighbor runs well now i
say ah
node little and then then takers one s
degree toe and  warm sdq history
walnut for om suggestion takers what
little s degree warm and who had past
the griev iii will take from this to
capture the degree of the need for or
the notes plus the the grace of the
takers
than one in four arby's teamview  there the
neymar cashier shovel that strange thicker
something with it would you sygo with it billion
immédiate let added notebook
the what the [ __ ] oh deeper into the
network geer
go to the neighbors take the tour need
to who can so tim visual and that is
a
wedding per rust ik zo nou let's
continue this investigation and look at
dan other pair of notes
lets look at no one en toe aan what is
interesting' is that when to actually
aan in dit graaf nu role in the network
card is team vision from one  another
because they can still symmetry
children like at the d above give those
three to
the neighbor a depot then
one of the rear of the great to and one
of the free free an easy go to the
second receiver good something
the need  number for the test agree to
show this kind third
network neighbor good is identical rig
arles schoudee borgart boogie explore the
network beacause in in both cases they
know they have each
each of them has one note of degree t  o
one note of the grief iii
take it well d beauvais observer of
the great to see god so know de arc and
observer of the gray was also
you can not the same with one and two and
less someone i use some features
information that italy appliances
housing tommen b are the count
structure
you can on the sting with limbic if there
can still be simek the third position
isomorphic I joke
my tablet and I can afterwards running
shampoo or try to be in dutch english and
how this  will work up zo
the key question wimona look at is kent
jane ennood en bij Denk the sting with
the frame loco
take good structures leads loco mini
take good structures to the active
need and die [ __ ] kent question i swim
en who understands what is the  premium dress cases
of power neural networks
sun so what we do nothing is unique
supports soon aygun in captures
take local good structures and more
voip understand is truly ski concept
of computational tomb i will
adapt my  k about what is a computational i
off ride or using conditions that each
player to take jane and aggregates good
neighboring combat x
sorry to jane and regenerist and
initiation while computational graff
the fine to structure the emergency number
so for x number of ivc air is still coercion  the
computational graff flats and je van je
due to layer jane en voor no one is
critique your brain no one ever get
information for notes to en 5 no the
years
need 505 aggregates information from its
neighbors and 5s nemer wang toe en voor
en no to  share a great information form
something nemer still compulsion in distress 5
solo what riko had computational
something in that show was method used
get worse i know that from level level
zero to lifelong increasing and this
is now one the computations please de with
crimes  the tour layer count new to
network for note to all those die wang
dance the ambiance and what is interesting'
is that well who needs van dijk for shampoo
he reported number  two and he create a
computations graf for something even if you
know something
how bad age from no one in five
5 of no gates from mine to
enter and break the emergency number one
aggregates from tour
n5 what your need is is that
computational
graff for  note one and two are actually
identical ones above him had children
from lemmer long and dehenauw one one
mind ear and cheek kindred spirit history
at glamor zero' so what nice nice big as
a jean en iso leading classics passing
information who builds a dino die die
seat only you ze snoot feature factors
die smits that you never succeed this
preparation
it is so computations graphs right now
they are different because i say ho'
hobby is not no is never number one
and geri's number two so abs least
reser diever maar dat
violin  i look at the colors of
young and also to the emergency
feature information they considered that
always look like they look out i think
and there is no way to their noot apart
from each other so enormous  case is to
engraving literally a cloth and aggregate
your holding formation of those fast two
brave him yellow color
and times i connecting hot yellow
cannabis oil can now is between kolev
trialogue everyone who is they look at
her yellow children and when foggy
eric a c&a in all its keys in it and
and disorder dung or any other long
history of order children and that's
I gave a describe this computations dry
but the property is that for to the front no
one and two
de competition' grafts there so
vital kenny  feature information who
drops a in distress attribute information
this to this to know this to
computations graff sardes a zo this
two note rugby embedded into so a
point
indian wedding space and what the smiths
is that davy consultation zo ben gravure
network will be able to the sting  love
and assemble my cooking classes final coercion
in two different klaas the no to be
caused er initiation cunning i say now so
one thing will consult bicos de de
com  putations graff arabic one
and there is no die stimpy show
note feature information microset can
lose samsung
queen so sweet berries and importance
line of this lecture
this is the most important slang is that
basically who
jane and scatcherd whatsoever contractor good
structure groede computers en count  en
computations graf of then ansar so a
take the two note
baby bath i said clean admit so
implantation die a bedding space which
means that we'll ok go to classify
when access class and the other one
into the yes work that precious
dr i  i think we had consultation i
will week and all that steam so this less
so this means just can of to summarize
is that in die simply shampoo van jane
and will generate the same introduction for
notes reside in to be cause of toe fact
first is  that beacause the computational
likes starters a bee hard-eyed i think
him and the sec and tim becomes a couple it
is that emergency feature information in this
case ih will think i drive to gay'  s the
assumption of this lecture is that
emergency features arnoud news nutrition this
case such a landscape so a feature neon
yellow
rides in that bag jane and that is never
care about
nobody's here cares about their tribute
features of the nose and engaged him
this means  that this game is not able to
the sting with no one and two
zo one and two minorly creation sea
cube m introduction
zo d biological be put into so
een klaas of things bios sign
so a label not to sissies
interesting' en de which now seems  quite
pipe band in copy design' pink save
it so [ __ ] i found a corner case ohra
ohra much air case for gravure networks
where this knee
can not hurt this team which mouth so
deporte that he wanted to make sure
is that in general the french  ockenburgh
good the fine die friend computing' grass
drives so and gerard computations graff
for diferent note there is
competition' grass for note one and two
computations grass for note 3 one for
as well as computationa  l grave for note
5 solo biologist who after we will be able
to the steam which one into the coast
guard is a
computation grass net that song that fact
of life
there is not much i can do wat de
question stille the mains
galabal op zee en  for or three and five
how long granular try me to the
sting which the snow i was but who is
now the prefer a computational grass
so perhaps the count now rapport is able
to the member or capture the structure of
the computation graf
which means that notes  train for will get
a different introduction that costs more
computations crosser deep
my wish the in some sense the week
issue is running
so busy a what and what is the point is
the plank is that computational graff
its identical to toe the route tab 3
structure from the  channel
but I so weekend think of this route
sap 3a disease die fines the tops
logical structure of the take
good button and add notes
we take to distinguish do in the
best-case even they have differ  ent route
chuck thery structures idea prefer
a computations race of course media
but from now on the led becomes history and
perfect that is not i was able to the
sting decided that gives that friend
computations gras opinion that the
structure of the third street is deeper
and  maria joint look at next is another what
cases in al kent toe and stream the sting
away and in my case is touring screaming
and simply be
lamp toe kenter into the same in am
i can of to continue on the site
jane in snowdin pennings capture  route
chuck thery structures dbc cap demons
capture the structure of the graph or the
computational graph of the network take
it easy you need me and the most
expressive graph now an app
for
how the map that friend soots the juice dries
into the friend  needed at drinks reign
of chambéry presented by different
colors white zo one and to be caused
p to the same point der is
another week and through london
who the core definition no gravure
fax to what jumper note 3 4 and 5
dedon crazy but i think i also
competition' gras structures so they
should be map in two different points
indian wedding  striker
right zo the most expressive graff nu
network will basically
be able to learn more capture what is the
structure of the computers and power and b
are the structure of the competition degree
of sign a different initiation for each
computational to this is the main
premiums that  four arms kink you who
live and sure dative to note ship rather
a computer graphs
then there map to different points
indian wedding space
en de question is king graaf nu al
networks doe de there is an important
concept from automatics that you allah
was to  make further progress in
understanding wiser and from now on an at
work can take two different computation
grave
do that strange to we route the juice dries
and my them into different points i  n the
embedding space and there is the snow
his ear definition still what a in jack
new functions and a function with maps
from the death of the by my ex but to
do mainline who scores in jack lief lief
it maps different elements into the
different outputs
so what is basic suddenly that there is fairytale
information of mr wright this becomes a
crime there were what again input
should get your is mine now that
stinks
that stinks pine species that stinks
outputs mini for is barely anything to go to
bed in the street  coke and you must that you
so an output will receive an input
maps to a different output best
definition of in jackie and
who wants this is a very important concept
i see as a jeweler
but for the rest of the lecture on
quite him so who  man of know-how
expressive is off mother network and
most expressive graff duo network
shake brand die sap dries this
computation graphs then already the embedding
in jack deeply believe that before
that friendship three wi  sselt me put
into a different point in the embedding
space on any dirty mapping snapped in
jack team
opinion that tutti frutti input study
frame sap dries get map toe so a find
them on this is not in madness mapping
and that's big so who monarch him  and
school that digs
orly living that does on a gravure just
becomes the cosby's in jack the mad
king rather became a juice dries
get map in two different points indian
wedding space
so the keyuser girl you after last
make progress is that dries or so a
that can be free pillow not correctly
arise from the leaf notes to the root node
zo Martijn niet bij die cissé who can
glue the sting with one or the
three
den via able ricoeur simply take this
lemmers and some game to gather into an
unique  description of the trie
so he had min by the sith for I
simple and the contractions can connector ice the
trie is simply by the number of children
age notez
bright so for disaster government je
coetzee ah walked to the lower lemmer  st
renamer free children and the other emergency
gas
hooter and ben you can chn ben necessary
soot
it limits limits
childrenswear so like and correct rises
bch to you no
who give risers at lely very
convinced renamer is that only the
syrup and the  understand when
takers from lemmer lemmer my wife for
jointly for a this particolare
computation force he no wine guide
times 3 traction return and think you
have dessert drinks so this description
is that strange the ben descriptions ever
wrong with a go to step truth out of
the sting who knows win this to the
college friend
it's think board and tens that there is
you can glue that compost at level
sorry of able to capture the structure
of a single angel or the three perception
of josh die clever
the
me a recursive lead to  this love by
just as what timing is to whom you don't
glue the focus on golden you correct journey one of these
computations graf for this route the sap
3 had it on the n  ew note of interest
so let's continue thinking and
setting of the source
so sweet each step of jane and uncle
creation process can fully
mariet a de neighborhood information
mini how many children
take so that's also new note gerf den
degenerate it emergency introduction skin with
team  with the friend
sap dries trucjes ride the bike and c&a
glamor warm in
in mein teri yes admit tucci erin in
that old men hair free in the [ __ ]
kan of caption this information
propagate that ton de leeuw had when the
emergency coercion and in this other  three item
kan of captured information at one one
knows his wild and the other notez three
children
drove via able to the steam want to
point out the pointees
in samsung's arm heyward we ruled
information from the children and
somehow storied so we don't necessarily
pledge where w  e parenting de trie this
information and gets retail
als in this case the information dat
aan street great and all the way up to
the root of the tree that de questi a
nuance so in other words what you
just go to do is the one ac dat  the
most expressive graph mother network to
use an in jack team take good
decoration for each step for each player
of the or for each gluing of the
computations oil smith that type my
dear cousin good in two different
embedding suffers so much the problem
becomes  to capture the number of children
to level one what will that one from lemmer glue out
very long and there is no
disk and or rode one this information as
their [ __ ] i other three so that the
trie
as just my your children age or something
on youtube bike
take never have so they century the
idea
so the summary safari is the formation to
generate and holding at the game and
user sap computational graf that
correspond was
routes actress structure from the button
so
for this he
still needs computational digging if necessary the cpu
and soot the sap tree structure that
describes the walking take good
structure oranges distress and his
diferent routes or trees prefer a
computational absolute that
distinguishable
here via using in jack lief take good
aggregation more
who only to the sting did not know
friend sap dries and the jinn and skin if
we slang lucy to jane and skinfood i
knew including there in step 3 structures
has
at every level something neighbor good day
revision mini guide aggregation for the
children
is a  madness puccini was still information
get lost
so i think a foil correct rice the
computations gave andy's teams of
computation digs from the other